[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Thank you, everybody,
for coming here today.
I will do a short intro
for Robert Wright.
So Robert Wright is a
journalist, scholar, and prize
winning author of
bestselling books
about science, evolutionary
psychology, history, religion,
and game theory.
Robert Wright also taught
at Princeton University
about a connection
between modern cognitive
science and Buddhism.
Professor Wright
famously explained
in his book, "The Moral
Animal", how evolution
shapes our human brain.
And how our mind is designed to
create delusion about ourselves
and about our world.
So our mind is designed to
make happiness hard to sustain.
So how do we sustain happiness?
So today, Professor
Wright finds that answer
in the 2,500 years old teachings
by Shakyamuni Buddha, a prince
from the great land of India.
In his latest bestseller
book, "Why Buddhism is True",
he leads on a journey through
psychology, philosophy,
and Buddhist teaching to
show how and why meditation
can serve as the foundation for
a spiritual life in a secular
age.
Meditation can make us a
better and happier human being.
So I introduce you
to Professor Wright.
And please note that we have
15 minutes for Q&A and book
signings.
So if you have any questions,
please wait until the end.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ROBERT WRIGHT: Thank you.
Thank you for all the work
you did to make this possible,
and thank you all for coming.
I'm almost surprised these
days when anybody shows up
for a talk on Buddhism,
because the political situation
in America is so distracting and
engrossing that a lot of people
have trouble thinking
about anything else.
Of course, there is one
connection between meditation
and the political situation.
Some people are using
meditation as a kind of refuge.
Kind of to establish an island
of calm amid all of this stuff.
I think there's actually a
second kind of connection.
I think mindfulness
meditation, in particular,
can in a subtle way play
a productive role here
in, kind of,
contemporary politics.
And I want to talk about
that a little at the end
if I have time.
But first I want to talk
about the book a little.
Give you a basic idea
of what it's about.
And I think I pretty
much have to start
by addressing the title,
"Why Buddhism is True".
In fact, as a show of
hands, try to be honest.
This won't offend me.
How many of you when you see the
title, or first saw the title,
found it a little
obnoxious or off putting?
OK.
All right, you can leave now.
[LAUGHING]
AUDIENCE: I'm guessing
the answer's yes.
ROBERT WRIGHT: No, it's a
totally defensible reaction.
And so it is incumbent on
me to try to convince you
that the title is justified.
So for starters, what part of
Buddhism am I talking about?
I'm talking about what you might
call the naturalistic part.
I'm not getting into like, you
know, reincarnation and so on.
Talking about the parts that
are amenable to examination
via modern psychology,
modern philosophy.
And that's the kind of
examination I do in the book.
If you ask, what in particular
am I saying is true?
There's a number
of answers to that.
But one thing I'd say is
at the core of Buddhism
is the claim that
the reason we suffer
and the reason we make
other people suffer
is because we don't
see the world clearly.
OK.
We don't see ourselves clearly.
We don't see other
people clearly.
As a result, we
suffer needlessly,
and we behave badly
towards other people.
When you think about it, that's
kind of an amazing claim.
Right?
The idea.
Because it suggested that
by clarifying your vision,
by pursuing truth, you
could make yourself happier
and make yourself
a better person.
So that the idea is that truth
and goodness and happiness
can, in principle, converge.
So you can kind of
kill three birds
with one stone you might say.
Which is nice, you
know, convenient.
And, of course, Buddhism
provides the stone.
It provides a whole set
of teachings and practice
that are intended to
clarify your vision
and have these very welcome
consequences of that.
The practice
includes meditation,
and I focus a lot
on that in the book.
I talk about mindfulness
meditation in particular.
I'm sure all of you either
do it or have heard of it.
It needs no
introduction these days.
I think a lot of people think
of mindfulness meditation
as basically therapeutic.
They think of it as
for stress reduction
or dealing with anxiety.
And it can do those things.
But I think what's lost
is that there really
is a connection between
mindfulness meditation
and the depths of
Buddhist philosophy,
really deep issues in
Buddhist philosophy.
And I think people who are
doing mindfulness meditation
in a kind of therapeutic
way are closer
than they realize
to really serious
philosophical and
spiritual exploration.
And in the book I
try to provide some
of the background that will
help them make that connection.
Now, obviously, I'm
not the first person
to say that Buddhism is true.
Many people have said it.
Buddhists, for example, have
been saying it for 2,500 years.
Obviously the
premise of this title
is that I have something
new to say about that.
And you might ask,
who am I to claim
that I have something new to
say about a subject that's
been so discussed for so long?
The good news is I
don't claim that I
had some special meditative
revelation that I'm
going to share with you.
In fact, one difference
between this book
and a lot of books that get
into Buddhist meditation
is this book is not
by someone who is
especially good at meditating.
Many of them are by people who
are very good at meditating.
Meditation didn't
come naturally to me.
I finally had to go to a retreat
to see enough benefits for me
to really make it a practice.
I've done a number of retreats.
And on retreat, in particular,
I have had some experiences
that seem kind of deep.
But I'm not one of these adepts
who have these experiences
on a more regular basis,
or even in a sense
walk around in daily life
with the benefit of radically
different apprehensions
of the world.
But I did interview a
lot of these people,
and so their voices
are heard in the book.
And so I hope that helps my
exposition of my argument.
But still, I did not come
down from a mountaintop
with any kind of
special illumination,
you will be happy to hear.
What I'm arguing is that there
is a kind of illumination
of the logic behind Buddhist
philosophy and psychology that
is available now that
just wasn't available 40,
50 years ago.
And it's modern
psychology, and in
particular, evolutionary
psychology, which
is the study of how
natural selection designed,
so to speak, in quotes,
"designed" the human mind.
Now, I wrote a book about
evolutionary psychology
a long time ago called,
"The Moral Animal".
And one thing I realized
when I wrote that--
well, I realized a couple of
things that in retrospect have
real connections to Buddhism,
and I emphasized them
in the book.
One is that people are
not designed to be happy.
OK.
Natural selection, that's not
high on natural selection's
agenda.
The bottom line for
natural selection
is getting genes in
the next generation.
Traits that get genes
into the next generation
are the traits that flourish.
Whether they make you
happy, sad, or whatever.
And that seems to explain
why, as some of you
probably noticed, gratification
tends to evaporate.
Right?
You eat some food.
You have some sex, whatever.
Before long the
thrill fades and you
wouldn't mind having some more.
Right?
Now, that makes sense
from the point of view
of natural selection, right?
Because if you imagine animals
that were eternally contented.
If they ate one meal
and just sat there,
and boy that was great.
And didn't seek any
more food, well, they
wouldn't do well, right?
And so too with sex.
From natural selection's point
of view, more sex is better,
more chances to
reproduce are better.
So you wouldn't want someone
to just bask in the afterglow
forever after a
single sexual episode.
So this is consistent
with one thing
that the Buddha
emphasized, which
is that there is a lot of
suffering in life as ordinarily
lived.
And in fact, this
very phenomenon
is emphasized in Buddhism,
the fleetingness of pleasure.
And in fact, the word that
is translated as suffering--
duka--
a lot of people think that
a good translation of that
might be unsatisfactoriness.
And that certainly
meshes very well
with a kind of
evolutionary perspective.
It's unsatisfactoriness that you
would expect natural selection
to build into us, to want us
to always want a little more,
to be discontented.
Now, I said that Buddhism
emphasizes our failure
to see things clearly.
And you've kind
of seen that here
in the fleetingness of pleasure.
Because when we look
forward to pleasure,
we tend to look
forward to the pleasure
and not focus on the fact
that it will evaporate, right?
It's kind of an
unbalanced view--
that if you're thinking
about eating some junk food,
you're thinking about the
taste of the junk food.
Not that, you know,
maybe half an hour later
you'll be restless.
If there's some promotion
you've been gunning for,
you're focusing on the benefits
it'll bring, not the headaches.
That's just natural.
And you can say that
that's, if not an illusion,
a departure from perfect
balance of vision.
Now, you might say, well, that's
not quite a misperception.
It's just an
unbalanced perception.
And that's true.
And you might also say,
look, by and large, people
do a very good job of
perceiving things clearly.
They don't run into walls.
They have very good
navigational equipment.
That's true.
But even in that realm,
that simple pedestrian realm
of just perceiving
objects, you do see a kind
of illusion built into it.
So people tend to overestimate
the speed at which
large objects approach.
Now you can see why
that would make sense.
There's no way of knowing
for sure that that's
built by natural selection, but
it surely makes sense, right?
Because it's better
safe than sorry.
Better to get out of
the way of a big animal
or whatever too
soon than too late.
And I say that just to make the
point that strictly speaking
just as our happiness is not
high on natural selection's
agenda, strictly speaking
accuracy of perception is not.
If inaccuracy in perception,
if illusion will get genes
into the next
generation, then that
can be favored by
natural selection.
And in this realm of
better safe than sorry--
the principle that leads
you to overestimate
the speed of an object--
you kind of see how these two
things, illusion and suffering,
can again coincide.
So if you were like walking
through, taking a hike,
and you've heard that there
are rattlesnakes all over.
Every time you hear
a rustling, you're
going to kind of imagine
that there's a snake there.
If a lizard darts
across, you're probably
going to think it's
a snake for a while.
That's an illusion.
It's also unpleasant.
It's suffering.
But from natural
selection's point of view,
and maybe even from yours,
all those false positives
are worth it.
But the point is, again,
suffering, illusion,
they can make sense from natural
selection's point of view.
And then, on top of that,
living in an environment
that natural selection
did not prepare us
for compounds things.
So you take forms of suffering
that are in a sense natural,
like anxiety, and they morph
into a whole new difficult
to manage forms.
So, for example,
evolutionary psychologists
would say that having
anxiety about a toddler
is natural if it's your
toddler and they wander off.
You'll go, wait, something
horrible has happened.
Run after them.
But natural selection
didn't equip us for, say,
dropping a toddler
off at a daycare
center on the first day
where you don't know anybody
at the daycare center.
And so that's going to just
totally freak people out.
Right?
Or similarly it's natural to
have anxiety about how you're
perceived, because winning
the esteem of people
seems to have helped get
genes into the next generation
during human evolution.
But then in the
modern environment,
you put people in
situations like this.
They're addressing a bunch
of people they've never met.
And naturally people have
public speaking anxieties,
and they imagine crazy things.
There are people
who are recurringly
imagined that they
will projectile vomit
while public speaking even
though they've never done it.
And they believe it when
they're having the fear.
And so you've got two problems.
We were built to sometimes
suffer and not see things
clearly.
The modern environment in
some ways makes things worse.
It makes us imagine things
that aren't going to happen,
or are very unlikely
to happen, and so on.
So I fear that in talking
about anxiety and stress
I'm again making meditation
sound like a purely
therapeutic thing.
And I want to
emphasize that I do
think there is a lot
more to it than that.
In the book, I
focus a lot on two
of the deepest and pretty
central concepts in Buddhism,
I would say.
One is called not self.
The idea that the self is
in some sense an illusion.
And the other is
called emptiness,
which has a number
of interpretations.
But it's sometimes
put as the things
you see do not have
inherent existence,
or they don't have essences,
or something like that.
And so both things sound
pretty arcane if you hear them
for the first time.
And I'm not going have time
to get into them deeply here.
I would say,
though, just quickly
about not self-- a point I try
to emphasize in the book is
that when you do
something that is fairly
common in mindfulness
meditation, which is just
get a different vantage
point on your feelings,
such as the one
I just described.
Or even less dramatic than
what I just described.
But just suddenly you
have a little perspective
on a feeling that previously
you might have been barely
aware of, but you would
have kind of slavishly
actually obeyed, right?
And you get enough
perspective on the feelings
so that they're no
longer in charge.
And you may even exercise
some choice in whether you
follow their guidance.
Well, I would say that when
you do something like that,
you are making an incremental
step toward not self,
toward the experience
of not self.
And I look at the Buddha's own
early teachings on the subject.
And I think you can interpret
them very much in that spirit--
the kind of so-called first
discourse on not self.
Now, as for emptiness,
let me just close on that.
We'll talk about
emptiness, and then
get back to this question
of contemporary politics,
and then open it
up for Q&A. So I
had an experience on my very
first meditation retreat.
I talked about this in the book.
But I was taking a
walk through the woods,
and I saw a particular weed
called a plantain weed.
And it was a kind of
weed that had infested
my lawn for years and years.
And I had spent a lot of
time trying to pull it up,
trying to kill it.
And all of a sudden I just
couldn't understand why.
I looked at the
weed, and I thought,
this weed is just as beautiful
as all the other stuff
that we're not calling weeds.
There are no objective criterion
for distinguishing weeds
from not.
It's just some person
at some point decided
to call certain things
weeds, and so we all do.
But the feeling at that time
was that it didn't make sense.
And it wasn't just a logical
conclusion I reached.
It was a perceptual shift.
When we look at things
we consider weeds,
we sense a kind of
essence of weed.
And it's a subtle
thing, but it's
very much informed by feeling.
I would say it's
not just cognitive.
It's not just perceptual.
It's very much
infused by feeling.
And by the way, I would
say one thing in general
that I think Buddhist psychology
has been very prescient in is
the emphasis on the way feelings
subtly infiltrate what we think
of as cognition, and
shape our thoughts,
and attach themselves to
our thoughts, and so on.
But in any event, I didn't
see essence of weed,
and suddenly it was beautiful.
All the greenery was beautiful.
And by the way, if
you talk to people
who seem to walk around with
the so-called experience
of emptiness, they
say the same thing.
They say things project
their identities
less sharply than they used to.
That just seems
like a little less--
they know it's a clock
if they look at that.
And it's got less clock
vibe than it used to.
But they also say
everything is beautiful,
or they may say everything has
a positive energy or something.
So this brings us back
to contemporary politics,
in particular the
psychology of tribalism,
which I think is the big
problem with the world.
Wherever the conflict is--
sectarian conflict, ideological
polarization in America,
national conflict,
wherever you see conflict--
I think the problem
is what I call
the psychology of tribalism,
a somewhat misleading term.
But in any event, I would
say a set of cognitive biases
that lead us to--
well, involve identifying
with one group
and affect the way you
process information
relevant to your relations
with the other group.
And I think one good thing
about mindfulness meditation
is it makes you more aware of
how you're feelings trigger
certain biases.
So a good example is
the so-called fake news.
Right?
And now I personally
think almost all of us
have spread fake news.
I know I have.
There have been times
when I retweeted something
without going back and
examining the original source.
And I later realized
it had been misleading.
And if you ask what is it that
leads somebody to do that,
it's a feeling.
It feels good to
spread information
that is unflattering to
the group you don't like,
or flattering to the group you
like, or confirms the argument
you've already made.
This is sometimes
called confirmation
by evidence consistent
with your preexisting view.
I just want to emphasize it's
not just a cognitive bias.
There is a feeling
associated with it.
I think mindfulness
meditation can
make you more aware that
that's happening and leads you
to kind of pause and reflect
before sharing the fake news.
Now, to get back to the
essence thing and emptiness.
I think the most
consequential arena
for emptiness and for not seeing
essence of is the human realm.
Because we do.
And again, I think this is a
product of natural selection.
We do tend to see essence
of rival, essence of enemy,
essence of friend,
essence of ally.
And these perceptions
shape the way
we process information
about them.
And there's one
particular cognitive bias
that hasn't been discussed as
much as I think it needs to be.
And I want to just
mention that quickly.
So this is called
attribution error.
The original version
of this was called
the fundamental
attribution error.
And the idea originally is,
as it was originally studied,
was when we try to explain
somebody's behavior--
why they did something--
we attribute too much
significance to
the kind of person
they are, kind of
essence, you might say,
and not enough to circumstance.
So if somebody in front of
you in the checkout line
is a jerk, is rude to the clerk,
you go, well, that's a jerk.
That's essence of
jerk, but for all you
know they just had a bad night.
I was actually a
little rude last night.
My flight from New Jersey
was eight hours late.
And so I was just
not in the mood
to find that they did not
have any rental cars for me.
And I kept it fairly
well under control.
But I like to think
that wasn't the real me.
Anyway, psychologists
have found that--
they originally found that
there was this bias toward--
you might say essence--
attributing things
to a person's disposition
rather than to situation.
But then they found that it's
actually subtler than that.
And this is the
interesting part.
With our friends and allies,
if they do something good,
we attribute that to
their disposition,
to the kind of person they
are, to their essence.
That's the kind of
person they are.
They do good things.
If they do something bad, we
have a situational explanation.
They didn't get enough
sleep, like me last night.
Or they were under stress.
They just got horrible news
about their family, whatever.
With our enemies and
rivals, it's the opposite.
If they do something
bad, it confirms our view
of what their essence is.
That's the kind of
person they are.
If they do something
good, we explain it away.
They just succumb to
peer group pressure.
They're showing off or whatever.
This is hugely consequential.
You may have noticed that
when we're ramping up
for war, people who favor the
invasion go to great lengths
to paint the leader
of the country
we might invade as
demonically as possible.
Sometimes these people
don't need much help.
Sometimes they're bad people.
But the point is that
if you favor invasion,
it makes sense to put
them in that enemy's box.
Because once they're there,
it's very hard to get out.
But anything good they do
will be explained away.
Anything bad they do will
confirm the initial image.
And I think the same thing
plays out in our politics.
So I think just a great
contribution mindfulness
meditation can make
here is to make
us more aware of the feelings
that trigger various cognitive
biases.
That get us to retweet things
or share them on Facebook
without checking them.
That get us to think
unfairly unflattering things
about people.
And to get back to
natural selection--
I think to become
aware of your feelings
and decide whether or
not to do their bidding
is almost to launch
a kind of rebellion
against natural selection.
Because feelings are
just the key levers that
are used to kind of
get us to follow what
you might call natural
selection's agenda.
And parts of natural
selection's agenda are great.
It built a lot of things into
us that I'm grateful for--
love, gratitude itself,
speaking of being grateful.
There's a lot of nice things.
But I think we have
the power to look up
at the process that built
us, decide whether we
want to follow as dictates.
And I think meditation
can be a big help here.
I just want to quickly
say two things,
and one is just a
bit of promotion.
I started a site called
mindfulresistance.net.
I only started it
a few weeks ago.
Right now we're just putting
out a weekly newsletter.
Of course, the
term resistance has
become associated with
resistance against Trump,
and I have to admit
I'm not a fan of Trump.
But I mean resistance a little
more broadly and deeply.
I mean fighting the forces that
gave rise to the mess we're in,
which certainly includes
the psychology of tribalism
and also includes a lot of
social political things.
Figuring out how to
respond to challenges
posed by globalization,
technology, and so on.
But my own feeling is that
a lot of opponents of Trump
overreact to him in ways that
actually play into his hands.
That's kind of an aside.
But in general, I
think that whatever
fight you're fighting,
fighting it mindfully
is just good strategy.
And not getting too sucked
into reacting to things.
So that's mindfulresistance.net.
Final thing, and I should
admit before I say this,
I am prone to
apocalyptic thinking,
so you should discount
this accordingly.
But I think you
could make the case
that we are at a
point in history
where the only alternative to
much deeper chaos and strife
is for people to become more
aware of how their minds work
and seize some control,
some conscious control
of that process.
Meditation isn't the
only way to do that.
Now, in my experience,
it's the most effective.
But there are various ways
to become, including just
reading about cognitive biases.
There are a lot
of ways to get out
what you might
call metacognition,
but I think we
may need something
like a metacognitive revolution
if the planet is going
to do what it is poised to do.
Which is, kind of
cross the threshold
to form a cohesive
global community.
As opposed to just collapsing
back into chaos, which I think
is a real possibility
given some of the forces
I see at work and some of
the positive feedback loops
that are at work.
But I think one
way or other people
need very much to get clear on
how their minds are distorting
their perception of
reality and warping
their judgment of others and
their treatment of others.
And if, as Buddhism
suggests, that makes them
not just better people
but happier people,
well, that's a nice bonus.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 2: So we have time for
a Q&A. Anybody with a question?
AUDIENCE: I have
a question here.
So you just mentioned the
political situation here
in the US.
It sounds like a
lot of people are
having a lot of illusions
over the other side,
probably that's causing
a lot of conflicts.
I wonder if there's a way for
them to calm down and really
have a meaningful discussion
instead of fighting each other?
Thank you.
ROBERT WRIGHT: Yeah.
That reminds me of another
thing that I consider
a cognitive bias that
doesn't get discussed much
in these terms, and it's this--
and I think this may be built
in by natural selection, built
into the mind, but
that's conjecture.
But you may have
noticed that if you
try to explain why someone
who did something bad
did the thing, somebody will
immediately say, oh, so you're
saying it's not their fault?
You're saying
they're not to blame?
Well, to take a--
no, I won't get into that.
The recent example is
too highly charged.
But if you try to explain,
like, why do people join ISIS?
It's like, oh, you're saying
the terrorists aren't to blame?
You know?
And this is an example of
an impediment to what you're
talking about, which is
sitting down and just
trying to understand
if you're anti-Trump,
why people voted for Trump.
I have three siblings who voted
for Trump out of four siblings.
So it's three to
two if you count me.
And it's hard.
[LAUGHS] I'm so angry,
but this is the big--
[LAUGHTER]
-- this is the biggest
challenge we face.
And I'll do another plug.
I have a platform
called bloggingheads.tv
where we try to do a better
job than many platforms do
of hearing the other side.
I've had a number
of Trump supporters
on and talked to them.
But it's hard.
And that's why I say I have
some hope that just mindfulness
and meditation, if it
continues to spread,
will play a positive role.
And I want to
emphasize one thing.
One thing people say
is, wait a second,
if our side meditates and we are
calm, they'll just run us over,
right?
No, I think
unilateral disarmament
in this context works.
OK?
Because I think-- to
get back to Trump--
I think a lot of times
when people aren't calm
and reacting to him,
that's what he wants.
That's playing into
his hands, because it's
feeding his narrative
that everyone hates him.
That narrative
appeals to his base.
And that's just one example
of how, in general, I think
with these kinds of conflicts--
Now, obviously, if
it's an armed conflict,
and you literally surrender your
weapons and they come kill you,
that is not good strategy.
But I think in this realm
we're talking about,
just deep political
polarization,
I think that progress on
one side, on either side,
can set in motion
forces that will
lead to a kind of calming
effect on the other side.
And it can be a virtuous cycle.
But this is a huge challenge.
SPEAKER 2: So to ask questions,
please line up back here.
I guess it works out
better for the AV
if we just line up and ask.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So you
started to touch on this
with the political resistance.
So if someone who's skilled in
meditation has a tooth ache,
maybe they can
contemplate the pain
and behold it and
view it with distance.
But at what point should
they just go to the dentist?
And where does the desire for
contentment with your situation
end, and when you should start
to think about making a change?
Like, why don't we just--
could we just sit passively
and tolerate the administration
because we're very
good at dissociating?
ROBERT WRIGHT: The
tooth ache thing
I actually did, and I
describe in the book.
I was on a retreat, and I
developed an abscessed tooth.
And when I drank any liquid,
it was excruciatingly painful.
So I meditated for half an
hour, just as an experiment,
and then had a lot of it.
And it was a surprising thing.
I don't mean it took
all the pain out of it,
but it kind of vacillated
between acute pain
and just going, whoa, that's
an amazing wave of pain.
And when I did that,
it didn't hurt.
It was really surprising, but
I know that's not the question.
The question is
with actual teeth.
The answer is you should
go to the dentist.
But I think the main context
for your question is--
well, you hear this a lot, tell
me if this is what you mean.
Will meditation kind of end
my passion for social justice,
or for change, or for resistance
against forces of oppression?
And to be honest,
I have seen people
who had gone so
far down the path
that I think that had happened.
I think it's very rare.
I think for people
like me, you care
enough about certain
issues that the challenge
is to pursue them wisely
and not get caught up
in your hatred of the people
on the other side and so on.
So it's like a larger
philosophical question
associated with
Buddhism, of nihilism,
which I won't get into.
But it's an interesting
"in principle" question.
In my experience, in practice
it doesn't arise very often.
But anyway, I would say
if you get that far,
if you're so good at insulating
yourself from the world--
which in a certain sense is part
of what meditation is about,
learning to get
better at coping.
If you get so good
that you don't care,
then I would say you've gone
farther than I want to go.
It doesn't happen often.
AUDIENCE: Well,
it's not a question.
Could you talk about
more about the projects
you are working on right now?
How they can really
help the society?
Thanks.
ROBERT WRIGHT: The
mindful resistance thing?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
and if you can talk
about several other things.
The one that you are feeling
most interesting about
or meaningful about.
ROBERT WRIGHT: Yeah, OK.
Well, the mindful
resistance, like I
said, we started
it a few weeks ago.
The URL is
mindfulresistance.net.
All we're doing right now is
putting out a weekly newsletter
kind of summarizing events.
And we're still
finding our voice
but trying to do it
in a different way
than people in the
resistance per se do it.
And both not get caught up in
reacting to every provocation,
and also trying to
convey what's going
on in the minds
of the other side,
of people who support Trump.
Because a lot of time
that doesn't come through.
Because most people who oppose
Trump don't watch Fox News.
But I think it's
illuminating to know that.
Now, honestly, this is, I
hope, just the primordial stage
of this project.
And that eventually
we will actually
try to get people
mobilized to try
to become more productive
citizens in the way
I've described.
You know, try to actually make
a point of not sharing news
without checking it out.
And not needlessly
ridiculing people
unless you're pretty sure
it's going to be productive.
There have been times in history
where ridicule was important.
But I would like to
develop an actual program
for applying mindfulness, in
the everyday English sense,
to participation in
politics, in public life,
by just regular citizens.
Because I think that's
where it has to go.
If you ask, well, why do various
opinion leaders, people on CNN,
Fox News, MSNBC, why do
they seem so incendiary
in the way they talk?
Because they get positive
reinforcement for it.
They get viewers.
They get retweets.
Ultimately, in that sense,
the people are in charge.
It's just that it takes
a whole bunch of them
to make a difference.
In other words, I don't
want to confine this
to people who meditate.
At the same time, I think
meditation can be very helpful.
And I do want to emphasize
to people who don't meditate
that mindfulness meditation--
if you look at the term,
and the origin of the term,
and the choice of
the word "mindful"
to translate to Buddhist term
"sati" and all of this stuff--
they may think of mindfulness as
just like, whoa, stop and smell
the roses.
Or just getting
absorbed in yourself
and like, oh, my feelings.
But ultimately, mindfulness is
about real clarity of vision.
The person who chose mindfulness
to translate the term
"sati", a British civil
servant and scholar
who went over to, I
think, Burma and got
engrossed in the culture.
He said that the Buddhist
ideal of so-called right
mindfulness-- and this
is one of the eight
factors in the Eightfold
Path in Buddhism--
is sati, mindfulness, what's
been translated as mindfulness.
He said it's like a
clear, alert mind.
That is mindfulness.
Not unswayed by emotional
reaction, just clear and alert.
And I think that would
be real progress.
AUDIENCE: You talked a lot
about mindfulness as potential
to overcome cognitive biases.
And there seems to be
a lot of literature
about the problems
with cognitive biases,
and that they do,
in fact, exist.
In the book, do you
go over evidence
that mindfulness
can in fact overcome
these cognitive biases?
I'm aware of mindfulness
reducing anxiety and increasing
compassion, but
in terms of seeing
more clearly biases, is there--
ROBERT WRIGHT: I'm not aware
of studies that have been done.
I know I gave a talk before
the book came out at Rutgers,
and a couple of people
there made the suggestion
that they should
start working on that
and actually study
whether mind-- it's
a fairly straightforward
thing to study.
You have a control group and
another group that meditates,
and you give them
cognitive bias tests
at the beginning and the end.
And so I don't know
what's become of that.
I'm not aware of--
in fact, I'm not
that aware of a lot
of work on the role of
feelings and emotions
in triggering cognitive biases.
But I feel very strongly,
just intuitively
and based on meditative
introspection,
that that's really fundamental.
That it's all about feelings,
in terms of triggering them.
AUDIENCE: So how do you deal
with the conflicting experience
with really attributing an
error to somebody's character
just because you don't
know them clearly?
Where the natural instinct
of considering the worst case
scenario, where there might be
something that's really wrong,
or it might be just
because you're not
able to see it really clearly.
And you don't know what
exactly the person is
or what exactly the--
ROBERT WRIGHT: So you
mean how in everyday life
should you go about trying to
figure out what the issue is?
AUDIENCE: In general,
especially in a lot of cases
when we deal with
a lot of people
we may not know exactly
what the thing is.
But one of the primitive
natural instincts
is when something
doesn't appear right,
we tend to think negatively
and attribute negative aspects
to people or
situations or groups.
So how exactly is
suggestible to deal with it?
ROBERT WRIGHT: Yeah, I
think I would advocate
a stance of firm agnosticism.
In other words, sometimes
you just don't know.
Until you know more
about the situation,
you just don't know
whether they regularly
behave like this in
all circumstances,
or they just had a bad day.
So you reserve judgment.
And this issue of
judgment is like--
you hear it a lot in the
context of mindfulness.
It's like, don't make
judgments, don't make judgments.
And sometimes people
dismiss that like, what?
You don't have values?
You don't make moral judgments?
And it's not that.
It's just don't make judgments
about stuff you don't know.
And that's very hard.
And I get into this
in the book about how
our brains seem designed to
make really quick judgments.
If a quick judgment is
right 51% of the time,
then from natural
selection's point of view,
in certain circumstances,
it might be better
than agnosticism, right?
But that's not a good
reason for reaching quick--
AUDIENCE: In a lot
of situations it
might be required for you to
be able to evaluate or come
to a decision than
just keeping it
as an abstract way
of understanding
and just dragging it forever.
ROBERT WRIGHT: Well, do you
have a specific kind of example
in mind, where you
might have to--
AUDIENCE: For example, my
point that I'm coming from
is-- there could be a lot of
people with inherent biases
as well.
But then they actually have
those biases because they
actually believe in them.
Whether intentionally
or unintentionally,
somehow the brains
get programmed
because of the past
experiences or whatever.
But then they may not be
able to really see the facts
but still need to
make decisions.
Let's say whether they want to
continue working with somebody
or not, or whether they want
to really stay with someone
or not.
Even like hiring
someone or not, things
like that, where
you can't really
indefinitely delay things.
ROBERT WRIGHT: Yeah,
so you're talking
about like group stereotypes
and biases, like ethnic bias,
and so on?
I think that some of the
social science literature
shows that what's
most constructive
is if you find yourself in
a non-zero sum situation
with somebody in that group.
In other words, you can
benefit by, in some sense,
doing business with them,
or it's in your interest
to collaborate with them.
I'm guessing-- I don't
fly business class--
but I'm guessing you don't see
a lot of expressions of bigotry.
Because for one
thing, you've got
these different ethnic
groups doing business
with one another, right?
It pays to be polite in
a situation like that.
There's a lot of
evidence of that.
And I think homosexuality
is an interesting case.
Because if you ask why
values changed so fast
toward acceptance
of homosexuality,
that was an interesting
case where a lot of people
knew gay people.
They just didn't
know they were gay.
And once gay people started
coming out of the closet,
then more people
started coming out,
and more people
and pretty soon everyone
had a cousin or a friend.
And so when you're in that kind
of relationship with someone,
you're just more
inclined to be tolerant.
And the challenge
is when there aren't
enough of those kinds
of relationships
between two groups.
And once it's torn apart,
it's hard to reassemble.
You know, Sunni and
Shia in Iraq used
to get together a lot better
than they did before the war,
before we invaded.
And so I don't know.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So I'm asking this question on
behalf of a group of Googlers.
We had this email
thread about this topic.
So recently there has
been a lot of effort
into secularizing
Buddhism, right?
ROBERT WRIGHT: Right.
AUDIENCE: So there is a
lot of focus on meditation
and mindfulness, but
then we leave out
the core aspects of Buddhism,
like reincarnation and cause
and effect.
So in Buddhism, there
are two concepts
to explain everything, right?
Like the relative truth
and the ultimate truth.
As a Buddhist myself,
in ultimate truth,
I don't believe
in reincarnation.
I don't believe in
cause and effect.
There is no self, right?
But in relative truth, for me,
not believing in reincarnation
is like I don't believe in time.
So if you consider
yourself Buddhist,
why not explain things
in those two concepts,
like in the relative truth
and in the ultimate truth?
ROBERT WRIGHT: So
by cause and effect,
you probably mean what's
commonly called karma, right?
AUDIENCE: Correct.
ROBERT WRIGHT: Right.
AUDIENCE: These topics
are considered esoteric--
ROBERT WRIGHT: I say that
because, just quickly,
one thing that's not
appreciated by Buddhism
is that karma aside.
It really puts a lot of
emphasis on cause and effect
in the scientific
side, in a sense,
at least as much as
Western science does.
If you really look at
what is meant by-- well,
the rationales for both
not self and emptiness
turn out to involve a really
pervasive appreciation
of the pervasiveness
of causal influence.
But that aside, first of all--
and I say this in the book--
I actually don't
call myself Buddhist.
Because I am doing
mindfulness meditation,
I'm doing it in the explicit
context of Buddhist philosophy.
And in the book, I defend
some of the fundamental ideas,
not self emptiness and so on.
But I just worry
that to Buddhists
who are Buddhist in a
religious sense, it might--
I don't know.
It might seem disrespectful
or something for me to show up
and say, well, you know,
I buy the philosophy
and the psychology.
So I'm going to call
myself a Buddhist.
I don't know.
I feel a little
awkward about that.
I think it's fine for people
who are doing so-called Western
Buddhism or secular Buddhism
to call themselves Buddhist.
I actually don't,
because I don't
get into karma, reincarnation,
and so on at all.
It's not part of my
practice or my belief.
Is that at all responsive?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah.
I have read that
some Buddhists--
hardcore Buddhists-- they say
that the dilution of Buddhism,
what's happening in
the West, is actually
a big threat to this
2,500 tradition.
Right?
ROBERT WRIGHT: Yeah.
In my experience,
my previous book
was called "The
Evolution of God."
It was about the
Abrahamic religions.
And one thing you notice is
just spiritual traditions evolve
forever, and they branch off.
Look at how many different kinds
of Buddhism there are, right?
And there are some non-trivial
differences of doctrine within.
That's one problem some people
have with why Buddhism is true.
There's no one Buddhism.
And that's why I focused
on pretty core concepts
like not self.
So that's one thing you can
say is that in a certain sense,
every version of
every religion is
threatened by its own future
evolution in a certain sense.
Just quickly-- one thing that's
characteristic of Western
Buddhism is meditation.
Westerners think
that Buddhists are
people who meditate and
don't believe in God.
Well, in Asia, that's the
opposite of the truth.
They do believe not in a single
creator God but in deities.
And they don't
meditate by and large.
Laypeople don't
meditate in Asia.
But actually, the tradition--
AUDIENCE: That's the laypeople
you're talking about.
ROBERT WRIGHT: The
laypeople, right.
But what I was going to say
was even there, in Burma,
in the late 19th
century, in reaction
to colonial occupation, they did
establish a big lay meditation
tradition.
And a lot of Western--
kind of Theravada,
Vipassana Buddhism--
traces its lineage to that.
So in a certain
sense, this feature
of so-called
Western Buddhism has
roots in Asian Buddhism
as it evolved in response
to forces 100, 140 years ago.
So on the one hand, I
definitely respect the view
that Western Buddhists should
not call themselves Buddhists,
and that's why I
don't call myself one.
But at the same time--
well, I guess I certainly--
another way to look
at it is, isn't there
something valuable about
what's happening in the West?
A. And B, I think it's richer if
informed by Buddhist philosophy
than if not.
And in a way this gets
into the whole issue
of cultural
appropriation and so on,
which is above my pay grade.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: You have a question
on the mindfulness meditation
potential, in terms of
introducing that early in life.
I think many of us have accessed
some of these tools later
in life than we
would have hoped.
And it seems like there's
a lot of potential
to offset some of the
negative aspects that
are just fundamental
to our nature in terms
of the tribalism and the biases
that we absorb over time.
What are your thoughts
on the potential
to introduce these tools
maybe earlier in life?
ROBERT WRIGHT: Oh,
I'm all for it.
AUDIENCE: And are you
seeing any trends?
ROBERT WRIGHT: I'm all for it.
And this gets to the question
of Buddhism as a label.
Because if you
talk to people who
are trying to introduce
mindfulness meditation
in the public schools,
a lot of them will say
it's a lot easier if they don't
use the word "Buddhism," just
as a political matter.
We have one
congressman so far as I
know who is into mindfulness
meditation, Tim Ryan,
and he has found in talking to
his constituents and so on he
needs to emphasize that
this is not at odds--
the part of Buddhism
he's talking about
is not at odds with any
existing religious heritage
these people may have.
And I think he's by
and large not using
the term "Buddhism" a lot.
The people who are--
there's like a "Mindful
Magazine" or something.
I think something mindful.
And they don't want to talk
about Buddhism, because they're
introducing meditation into
institutional settings,
corporate settings, and so on.
So to some extent, that
divorce from the label
is going to happen
as part of the quest
to more deeply ingrain our
society with meditation.
And maybe it's a worthwhile
trade, I don't know,
but I'm certainly in favor
of starting people young.
AUDIENCE: So our
modern environment
has produced conditions
in everyday life that
are not conducive to
sustained focus and attention.
What are some of
the consequences
of our fractured
attention spans?
And does current science
provide any insight?
ROBERT WRIGHT: You're
asking the right person.
I've always had
attention problems.
I never emerge from
a college lecture
with a coherent set of notes.
And I tried.
I really did.
I just couldn't do it.
And one thing-- I get into
this a little in the book.
The point is just that,
again, as is often the case,
attention problems
are largely I think
problems of affect, of feeling.
If you pay attention--
like if I'm trying
to do some writing,
and I suddenly switch over
and check my Twitter feed,
or get back to researching some
smartphone I'm going to buy.
If you look at what's
actually happening,
first, I've reached a
point in the writing
where it's not coming
easily, and that
makes me feel uneasy
and uncomfortable.
That's a bad feeling.
Something pops in my mind
like researching smart phones,
checking my Twitter feed.
It gives me a good feeling.
And it's that simple.
Attention is very much an
affective issue, I think.
Now, the problem's gotten
worse because there
are so many people
on the internet
trying to get you
addicted to things.
The other thing I'd say is I
think one reason meditation
retreats seem to be
growing in appeal
is because one thing they do--
set aside the meditation-- they
can just get you off the grid.
And by the way, if you go
to a meditation retreat,
I strongly recommend you put
your email on auto reply,
leave your smartphone
at home or whatever.
Just get totally
absorbed, no news
from the outside world,
that for my money
is a way to do a
meditation retreat.
I just think that so amplifies
the beneficial effects
of the meditation itself.
And it's a good reminder.
Of course, in the end, you have
to go back to the real world.
And this is, of course, the
problem of meditation retreats
in general.
They end.
And then it's everything
that came easily
by the end of the
retreat is harder.
But it's still a good
reminder of how much--
if a retreat goes well-- they
usually do in my experience--
by the end of the retreat, your
state of mind is so different.
It's just a reminder
of how in everyday life
your mind is just pushed
and pulled increasingly
by electronic things.
So you're probably young
enough you don't really
totally remember the
pre-internet world.
Believe me, it was different
SPEAKER 2: OK, again, we'd
like to thank Robert Wright
for coming here today--
ROBERT WRIGHT: Well,
thank you for having me.
SPEAKER 2: --and engaging
us in this very interesting
discussion.
ROBERT WRIGHT: This
was really great.
SPEAKER 2: Once
again, thank you.
ROBERT WRIGHT: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]